non plus pour protéger votre enfant
vaccinez-le à temps c'est le message de
la caisse primaire d'assurance maladie
des ivelines la vaccination petite
enfance comme véritable enjeu de santé
publique à la rentrée l'organisme
lancera une campagne sur l'ensemble du
département où la situation est plutôt
contrasté on peut dire qu'elle est
globalement assez comparable au niveau
national mais par contre nous sommes
assez nettement en retrait par rapport
aux recommandations du calendrier
vaccinal c'est-à-dire que les enfants
sont vaccinés mais ils sont vaccinés
souvent avec retard à titre d'exemple 59
% des moins de 24 mois sont à jour de
leur vaccin hépatite B loin des 80 %
souhaités par l'État un retard qui
s'explique peut-être par la
méconnaissance de certains parents du
calendrier vaccinal au cours de ces deux
premières années un enfant est beaucoup
plus vulnérable à certaines maladies
telles que la rougeole ou la coqueluche
aujourd'hui on recommande de débuter la
vaccination à l'âge de 2 mois avec un
vaccin exavalent qui comprend la
diphérie le tétanos la poly polyomélite
hémophilus qui sont des un agent de de
mélingite cocluche hépatite B et le même
jour on pratique dans l'autre cuisse du
bébé le vaccin contre le pneumocoque qui
est un agent infectieux qui donne des
ménagites sévères chez le tout petit on
commence à l'âge de 2 mois fait 2è dose
à l'âge de 4 mois et un rappel à 11 mois
autre raison possible de la situation
contrastée dans les ivelines la
réticence des parents certains sont
inquiets et se demandent par exemple si
le système immunitaire de leur enfant
est assez mature pour pouvoir répondre
vaccin je leur explique que le système
immunitaire de leur enfant est stimulé
de manière extrêmement précoce par de
nombreux virus bactéries qui sont dans
l'air sur la peau du bébé dans ses
intestins et que le vaccin représente
une toute petite stimulation immunitaire
qui va être extrêmement bien tolérée par
le vaccin la campagne de prévention pour
la vaccination des tout petits se
poursuivra jusqu'à la fin de l'année
2015 elle sera relayée par les médecins
et pharmaciens tandis que les parents
seront sensibilisés par courrier ou SMS
les a pour tout le monde